ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález hay malestar
social en bolivia las calles de las
ciudades de la paz cochabamba y santa
cruz las llamadas ciudades del eje
central han sido el escenario de
manifestaciones en contra de algunas
políticas del gobierno como por ejemplo
la llamada ley del gobierno contra la
legitimación de beneficios ilícitos
financiamiento contra el terrorismo y
financiamiento de la proliferación de
armas de destrucción masiva ese es el
nombre completo una ley que según
quienes la rechazan le otorgaría poderes
especiales al estado boliviano para
llevar a cabo una persecución política y
llevaría también algunas violaciones de
las cláusulas de confidencialidad y del
secreto profesional para los ciudadanos
bolivianos hay también convocado un paro
nacional que está previsto para el lunes
que abarca diferentes sectores de la
economía del país y también hay
convocadas varias marchas por parte de
seguidores del oficialismo hubo también
a lo largo de esta semana incluso
algunas
y concentraciones en diferentes ciudades
de bolivia mostrando su respaldo al
gobierno del presidente arce también
incluso hay malestar entre los cocaleros
que desde hace varias semanas han
protagonizado manifestaciones y
enfrentamientos en diferentes
departamentos de ese país suramericano
otros sectores han indicado que saldrán
a manifestarse contra la persecución
política con los juicios que están
avanzando en contra de algunos
integrantes de la oposición como por
ejemplo la ex presidenta interina de
jeanine áñez muchos temas muchos
aspectos sobre la mesa para este debate
podemos hablar entonces de una crisis
política eso es una de las preguntas que
queda entonces sobre la mesa la
situación en bolivia es nuestro tema de
debate hoy en france 24 y para
profundizar en este tema saludamos a
erika brockman ella es analista
politóloga y ex parlamentaria es de
nacionalidad boliviana y nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de la paz también está
con nosotros adolfo mendoza también
boliviano senador de la primera asamblea
legislativa plurinacional de bolivia
como vicepresidente de la asamblea
parlamentaria de europa de américa
latinael se encuentra en la ciudad de
cochabamba y aquí en el estudio de
france 24 está conmigo el profesor
esteban nina el es analista político y
magíster en economía también es de
nacionalidad boliviana se encuentra aquí
con nosotros en el estudio de france 24
ustedes también nuestros televidentes se
pueden participar en este debate con
todos sus comentarios preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter nos
pueden seguir como france24 guión bajo
esa santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 pero ya les
dije entonces las coordinadas en las
redes sociales tenemos los invitados y
tenemos el tema podemos comenzar
preguntándole a erika en la ciudad de la
paz pero me indican que primero
conectemos entonces con cochabamba con
el señor adolfo mendoza para comenzar a
abrir este debate se habla de una crisis
un malestar general allí entre los
bolivianos diferentes sectores
rechazando algunas de las políticas cuál
es su opinión
por mendoza sobre este tema hay
discrepancias y malestar por parte de
los bolivianos como lo vio usted
pues muchísimas gracias primero por
limitación santiago un saludo a quienes
nos acompañan en este diálogo lo primero
que tengo que mencionar es que en toda
democracia siempre hay construcción de
consensos y también construcción de
disensos a partir de hechos conflictivos
es natural que una
democracia se establezca a partir de
esta construcción de consensos y de la
conflictividad es algo que forma parte
de los procesos democráticos entonces lo
que sí debemos enfocar es el sentido y
la magnitud de la conflictividad para
ver primero si es que hay o no crisis y
si es que estos conflictos derivan en
una suerte de
debate en torno al propio sistema
democrático en nuestro país es en ese
sentido que hay algunas protestas
especialmente en
el último tiempo respecto de lo que ha
ocurrido con el tratamiento del proyecto
de ley sobre ganar ganancias ilícitas
algo que nuestro país debe hacerlo en el
marco de los acuerdos internacionales
con la gafi para el control de
precisamente éste ilícito a nivel
internacional y en realidad se trata de
un proyecto de ley que nada más lo que
hace es ordenar
algunos otros criterios normativos ya
existentes para cumplir con este
compromiso que el país ya había asumido
desde el momento en el que la gafi se
estableció ahora si bien hay otros
conflictos de orden local lo cierto es
que esto no puede leerse como una crisis
política es algo que forma parte yo
diría más bien de
actual circunstancia de haber recuperado
la democracia en nuestro país y la
necesidad de generar
mecanismos institucionales para resolver
estas demandas
ahora sí vamos a conversar con erika me
aclaran que ya no está en la paz está en
la ciudad de cochabamba también erika
bienvenida al debate y le hago la misma
pregunta hay una crisis hay un malestar
que lo que está sucediendo en bolivia
con esta pregunta partimos para el
inicio del debate
en primer lugar en salud y agradecida
por la invitación y un saludo a quienes
comparten este diálogo este debate y
auspiciado por france24
yo quiero indicar de que todavía no
podríamos hablar de una crisis política
espero que no se llegue a hablar de esa
crisis política en la medida que todos
los bolivianos sabemos lo que ello
implica en términos de poder y de
desinstitucionalización
lo que sí existe es un creciente
malestar un creciente malestar que está
ha sido acumulado en el marco de varios
conflictos que están incrementamos
malestar y
restándole el capital político a un
gobierno legítimamente elegido el 2020
en la cabeza de luís arce catacora un 55
por ciento de apoyo que en el marco del
conflicto y del malestar que éste que
ustedes señalan y que se pueden ver en
las imágenes
se opera en un marco de una
repolarización política donde los
extremos se estiran de una de una soga
con un nudo una serie de conflictos
altamente complejos comenzando por aquel
que se ha vivido en el tema de la coca y
que tiene implicancias para la
convivencia democrática e implica si hay
implicancias para la convivencia
democrática en tanto y en cuanto existen
voces estridentes que no están haciendo
desde la política que no están haciendo
caso
a las recomendaciones que hicieron el
grupo interdisciplinario
de estudios de
expertos internacionales lanier de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos que señalaba de una manera
tácita que existen que existe en bolivia
la tendencia que los líderes políticos
exacerben incentiven la polarización
política tanto de ambos extremos en toda
la radicalización se convierte en un pan
de todos los días pero yo quisiera
puntualizar que la ley
simplemente la ley contra las ganancias
ilícitas es una ley necesaria
lamentablemente se demoró en su trabajo
viene la comisión de la gafi en
noviembre y el gobierno se siente
presionado para cumplir con este
compromiso pero existen muchos elementos
que están en el debate en la mesa del
debate y que están disponiendo un país
80% informal de la economía vamos a
profundizar en esta ley y los aspectos
que abarca y el impacto que va a tener
en los ciudadanos bolivianos que son
directamente los que van a ver las las
los beneficios o consecuencias de esta
ley aquí en el estudio de france 24 el
profesor esteban ni na le pregunto para
cerrar esta primera ronda sobre su
impresión sobre este malestar que hay
entre los bolivianos este rechazo hasta
esta ley y las diferentes expresiones
ciudadanas de manifestaciones de
diferentes tipos en las diferentes
ciudades y departamentos del país
gracias santiago por la invitación y un
saludo a los colegas
pues yo diría que sí
estamos muy cerca de que el presidente
luís arce catacora
cumpla un año de gobierno y yo diría que
es también manifestación de ese primer
ciclo de desgaste de capital político
también por otro lado puedo ver que en
este gobierno del presidente luís arce
catacora hay ciertas continuidades y
rupturas
ruptura del sentido de que ya no están
actores como por ejemplo evo morales y
otros de otros dirigentes del mar hay un
cambio en un relevo que se esperaba hay
nuevos nuevos rostros como luís arce
catacora y el vicepresidente y otros
estados de ministros
yo diría que hay un cambio que permitió
digamos nuevas nuevas ideas nuevas
maneras de gobernar sin embargo hay
continuidad es como decía
la panelista erika brockman en la
polarización se sigue manteniendo esa
esa confrontación entre líderes
políticos especialmente del que más ha
liderado esto que es los comités cívicos
de santa cruz y otros afines a él de
manera que pone pone digamos trata de
poner algo en duda algo que no debería
estar al
albert que este presidente ha logrado un
apoyo en las últimas elecciones de un 55
por ciento devotos entonces eso le da
una gran legitimidad por otro lado
veríamos que ese trámite de la ley de
ganancias ilícitas si bien es una
exigencia internacional y eso estoy de
acuerdo y sin embargo creo que en el
trámite del diseño de esa política
pública no ha surtido unos pasos
necesarios como es la consulta con los
actores involucrados me gustó leer en la
prensa de que el ministro es y está a
una vez es eso tuve esta primera etapa
va a haber una segunda etapa de escucha
a los otros actores económicos y
políticos
para llamar en ruta a mi siguiente
pregunta porque genera tanta escozor
entre los los ciudadanos bolivianos esta
ley porque salieron a las calles a
manifestarse en contra de ella comienzo
la ronda esta vez por el profesor aquí
en el estudio de france 24 porque genera
tanto malestar
bueno yo creo que hay una tendencia
mundial este incluso ahora los
el caso de pandora los papeles de
fundadora señora los países fiscales uno
podría decir que en el mundo si hay esos
lugares donde hay el flujo de recursos
ilícitos
y digamos en bolivia también habría pues
hay mucha actividad informal como
también hay en américa latina entonces
yo diría que hay un flujo de dinero si
es el flujo monetario en un país que no
pasa por el control del estado
entonces yo creo que es ese momento en
que ya el estado está buscando
sentar soberanía sobre los recursos los
flujos de recursos económicos al
interior del país y hacia afuera y eso
me parece que es válido sin embargo creo
que hay una cultura también en américa
latina no obstante en bolivia de la
digamos de la evasión de elevación y por
ejemplo coincide mucho que en américa
latina y en bolivia la tasa de
contribución impuestos de pagar
impuestos por ejemplo a la tierra y al
día la renta y a la riqueza es muy baja
y entonces cuando un gobierno trata de
imponer eso viene el conflicto social en
el conflicto y salen los ciudadanos a
las calles a manifestarse
erika en la ciudad de cochabamba en esta
reforma esta ley que propone el gobierno
ustedes tres han coincidido en que es
una reforma que es necesaria hay
exigencias internacionales al respecto
pero porque los bolivianos la ven como
una un aval para que el gobierno
a
meterse en la vida de los ciudadanos y
empezar a consultar sobre sus capitales
sobre sus inversiones además que hay
muchos aspectos que no son muy claros no
no es muy claro si se pueden abrir
causas arbitrariamente por comprar un
carro o una bicicleta o algo en el
supermercado hacer una gran transacción
a través de una empresa a través de un
paraíso fiscal oa través de una compañía
financiera internacional
mira santiago yo lo que te puedo decir
es de que evidentemente aquí no se trata
de que solo la oposición se siente
está expresando su malestar con este
proyecto de ley creo que hay voces más o
menos racionales y de expertos que el
constitucionalistas que indican que
aprovechando esta ley se han incorporado
algunos dispositivos y algunos
articulados que podrían vulnerar los
derechos constitucionales que tienen que
ver con el derecho a la propiedad del
derecho a la confidencialidad del cetera
etcétera como se ha venido mencionando
yo quisiera referirme particularmente a
un hecho estamos viviendo una gran
desconfianza en el sistema judicial de
bolivia y en todos los sistemas y
mecanismos de represión del estado desde
hace mucho tiempo en las tendencias
autocráticas y autoritarias la detención
preventiva se ha convertido en algo
ordinario no algo extraordinario no
solamente en este gobierno sino en el de
prácticamente desde el gobierno de evo
morales
la justicia ha sido puesta en cuestión
hoy día toca fondo y no quiero decir que
también durante el el fallido gobierno
transitorio de jeanine áñez no se haya
abusado de estos recursos pero más tiene
el poder y la legitimidad y la
suficiente capacidad de movilización
para poder impulsar este tipo de ley y
no
el contención a las protestas y a los
cuestionamientos y mantener esta
tendencia autocrática yo no voy a hacer
voy a hacer referencia simplemente a dos
hechos se habla de terrorismo esta ley
se está construyendo sobre una
concepción y una tipificación del delito
de terrorismo y sedición que ha sido
observada por organismos internacionales
por naciones unidas como por la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos se ha
observado porque sería demasiado
rígida
por otro lado demasiado laxa e
incorporaría una serie de hechos y
eventos que podrían ser considerados
derechos constitucionales a la protesta
ellos han pedido que se reformule este
porque está esta tipificación porque si
se está montando una ley sobre contra
las ganancias ilícitas sobre este
criterio y concepto tipificado de
terrorismo y sedición que no estaría de
acuerdo a las convenciones
internacionales se estaría construyendo
una una ley que absolutamente es
atentatoria y una sociedad que es muy
informal y muy celosa de lo que
significa en el estado
adolfo su opinión al respecto sobre esta
ley está mezclando digámoslo de alguna
manera peras con manzanas unos ganancias
ilícitas con financiamiento de
terrorismo de armas de
destrucción masiva y también dándole
digámoslo más dientes al estado para
invadir un poco la vida de los de los
ciudadanos hay algunos analistas allí en
bolivia que han calificado esto como una
ley copiando un modelo de venezuela
tratando de controlar por parte del
estado y dando una persecución mucho más
grande a los adversarios del gobierno
pues santiago si me permites una
precisión antes de responder a tu
cuestionamiento es interesante ver las
imágenes que ustedes han mostrado y
explicar un poco estas imágenes en
términos del contexto porque en parte de
las imágenes las últimas que se han
mostrado son imágenes que se refieren a
momentos de felicidad a momentos de
reivindicación de haber recuperado la
democracia estas que estamos viendo no
tiene absolutamente nada que ver con las
propuestas que fueron bastante
focalizadas en el caso de santa cruz
esta es una marcha del día de ayer la
que estamos viendo allí en imágenes que
más bien intenta reivindicar la
democracia intenta generar un ambiente
en el que se reivindique reivindique e
incluso el uso de los símbolos patrios
notarás que allí la imagen es también
elocuente hay también ciudadanos que son
pocos y que están haciendo su
manifestación ahí evidentemente
debemos explicar el sentido de las
imágenes para no creer que de pronto hay
una impresionante convulsión social el
día de ayer se han mezclado muestras de
algarabía al respecto de la recuperación
de la democracia de la democracia en
bolivia respecto de la vindicación de la
wiphala y por supuesto también existen
estos otros elementos que vivió el país
el día de anteayer las mayorías
estuvieron presentes también en las
calles el día de la ley desde ayer esto
lo digo para un poco contextualizar el
uso de las imágenes y no dar la
impresión de que de pronto todo este es
en el ánimo de ustedes porque creo que
esa no es la intención de ver un país
convulsionado y agradezco lo que
nosotros intentamos hacer a adolfo algo
en la precisión
y que muestren varias imágenes se ve que
esos y
que quiere decir que ustedes están
trabajando de acuerdo a una ética
profesional adolfo lo que estamos
tratando de mostrar con estas imágenes y
gracias por esa aclaración es todos los
acontecimientos que ha habido a lo largo
de esta semana en bolivia y lo decía yo
en la introducción no hubo
manifestaciones por diferentes temas
tanto a favor como en contra del
gobierno y son las imágenes que estamos
viendo de las diferentes manifestaciones
que ha habido por parte de los
ciudadanos pero le pido por favor que se
concentren en la pregunta que le hacía
sobre si esta ley le da mucho más
alcance al gobierno para entrometerse en
la vida de los ciudadanos mucho más
control estatal y sobre todo hacer un
mayor control de los opositores
gracias una vez habiendo cuento expuesto
en contexto las imágenes y la muestra
que ustedes están viendo
no ambas caras sino en realidad
mostrando alegría por un lado y también
reclamo y protestas por otro lo cual es
loable y pasó a
trabajar el tema específico que solicita
santiago no hay en ningún punto del
proyecto de ley porque solamente es en
este momento un proyecto de ley no hay
en este momento ningún punto que nos
permita señalar que se está yendo más
allá de la pretensión de generar límites
ante los ilícitos que se dan en torno a
las ganancias que no son declaradas a el
terrorismo y a otro tipo de ilícitos
conexos como el tráfico de armas el
tráfico de órganos el tráfico de
personas
que también tienen que ver con la
discusión actual hay mucha
susceptibilidad al respecto pero lo
evidente es que para mostrar
verdaderamente que esto debería estar
que está exacerbando y se están teniendo
posiciones como las de venezuela habrá
que mostrar el texto y decir aquí está
esta es la prueba que esto está
extralimitándose y eso no es así porque
esta ley no tiene absolutamente nada que
ver ni siquiera con los ingresos
específicos de los sectores que están en
situación de informalidad es más bien
para observar el origen de las ganancias
por ejemplo si es que de pronto un
ciudadano tiene un ingreso habitual por
el régimen simplificado en el caso del
comercio o por su participación en el
empleo formal de diez mil bolivianos y
de pronto en sus cuentas aparece con
algún millón de dólares entonces ahí sí
se genera una situación de sospecha
algoritmos le pido por favor que sea
puntual porque me quedan son muy pocos
minutos este programa es muy corto y
tengo muchas cosas para analizar con
ustedes por favor muy puntual de usted
me habla de estas imágenes y me dice que
las imágenes no son de estas
manifestaciones que los bolivianos están
expresando felicidad reivindicando
algunas algunas cosas y en
entonces como entiendo yo las
declaraciones del presidente arce
diciendo que hubo un intento de golpe
que hubo un golpe fallido que una
conspiración antidemocrática y que
nuevamente están tratando y promoviendo
los diferentes disturbios para
desestabilizar el país es totalmente lo
contrario a lo que usted me está
diciendo
basta y usted es periodista a observar
las declaraciones del señor rómulo calvo
presidente del comité cívico de santa
cruz el día de ayer que lleva cuervos y
llama a la wiphala un trapo inservible
para dar cuenta de la actitud de odio
racial que existe en ese tipo de
discursos que son contrarios totalmente
contrarios a lo que ha manifestado
nuestro presidente luís arce catacora y
contrarios a la democracia
claro el punto aquí en el estudio el
profesor esteban nin a su opinión sobre
esta ley sobre esto estaba superando la
constitución lo que usted como que está
en riesgo la constitución
los
estados deben garantizar
esos ciudadanos y la igualdad de
igualdad y el respeto a la dignidad a
las personas por lo cual digamos los
sistemas los sistemas democráticos
tienen pesos y contrapesos entonces yo
diría que aquí como estoy de acuerdo con
la panalista de cada brockman que es
importante el rol que tiene la justicia
puede que haya un trámite legítimo en un
congreso de un país pues con ciertos
puntos positivos negativos pero luego
viene un control por parte de la corte
constitucional que debe garantizar los
derechos humanos y derechos sociales
si no hay es este contrapeso al final
esa ley puede puede atropellar a las
personas ya las comunidades entonces yo
lo que recomendaría es que al tiempo de
solicitar justamente este digamos esa
transparencia en los flujos de recursos
que decía el comunicador mendoza que
pueden incrementar repentinamente y eso
puede ser sospecha de algo también debe
garantizarse el debido proceso a esa
persona si y no y no y no y no atropella
digamos es digamos su fuero personal
entonces yo diría que hay que digamos
hay que prever también en la ley y
también una participación activa de las
altas cortes la pregunta sería esa y se
la quiero hacer a erika profesores si se
puede confiar en la institucionalidad de
bolivia en este momento en la
institucionalidad de los actores que
tienen que estar en este proceso y si
usted ve posible que esto pase y tenga
curso en el parlamento boliviano en el
congreso
yo creo que el gobierno está evaluando
seriamente la viabilidad de esta ley si
bien está con la espada de damocles para
cumplir un compromiso internacional con
la gafi creo que las manifestaciones
múltiples que se han dado de sectores
populares fundamentalmente se ha hiper
informados o también informados por
gente como por ejemplo williams bascopé
que es un abogado constitucionalista de
origen también indígena del sector
popular que he puesto pues se ha
punteado todos los artículos que a
partir de presuntamente podrían de
generar una serie de acciones en con
contrarias a la libertad de las personas
y en los derechos de las personas
entonces yo lo que creo es que ayer el
presidente estaba en la en el moon
palace o estuvo recorriendo por todo el
país apoyando estas manifestaciones de
grupos afines del gobierno que con justa
razón han se han sentido ofendidos y
están instrumentalizando el tema de la
wiphala como si fuese un símbolo
solamente del más yo creo que hay que
liberar a la wii como un símbolo
nacional pero que ha dicho el presidente
así como rómulo calvo debe ser censurado
y debe ser además
observado por su desafortunada
declaración en torno a la bomba la yo lo
que significa la migración joya en el
óxido en el oriente del país también
debemos el surf action presidente en su
alocución diga que si no se respeta a
las urnas creo que todos estamos
respetando las urnas y sabemos que tiene
cinco menos cinco años de período
constitucional si no se respeta las
urnas se va a ir a las tareas él va a
estimular las calles cuando todo lo
contrario debiera decir tengo todo una
plataforma institucional un entramado
institucional de la democracia que debe
ser el mecanismo y el espacio donde se
deben discutir entre diversos y entre
todas las personas que están observando
este tipo de situación el control
constitucional de esta ley sería
recomendable pero sería recomendable
todo en tanto este tribunal
constitucional hoy día está también pues
está bajo la mira
la desconfianza y la desconfianza de una
gran porción de gente que también votó
por luís arce catacora yo creo que de
ese 55 por ciento existe un gran 15 por
ciento que votó por la certidumbre
económica por las por la evocación de
los tiempos de bonanza pero que hoy día
está empezando a sospechar de que se
está reproduciendo una lógica
autoritaria y además es está
visibilizando el rol que lamentablemente
desde mi punto de vista es tóxico del
propio presidente evo morales que está
con una pretensión de convertirse hoy en
día en un líder de la confederación
andina de época de poca nivel regional
esto tiene implicaciones también para la
democracia nos quedan ya pocos minutos
para finalizar el programa adolfo
quisiera preguntarle esto de estas
manifestaciones y todo este debate que
estamos teniendo a casa en el contexto
de un primer año prácticamente ya ha
cumplido a punto de cumplirse el
presidente arce porque le ha costado al
presidente darse
y ganar la confianza de los ciudadanos
en las instituciones garantizarles que
las instituciones bolivianas funcionan y
están para servirle a ellos y en ganarse
la confianza del pueblo como lo ve usted
primero que la confianza del pueblo en
el presidente de luis arce catacora se
ha manifestado el día de ayer en la
democracia en las calles que es algo que
viven todos nuestros países en américa
latina y también lo vive europa esto no
es de extrañar es parte de las
construcciones democráticas del mundo
contemporáneo el segundo que
evidentemente más allá de haber logrado
el 55 por ciento del apoyo en las urnas
hace casi un año atrás la tesis
institucionalización que fue producto
del golpe de estado en noviembre de 2019
hizo que los ciudadanos también
agudicen su desconfianza respecto de
instituciones que ya no hacían cosa van
del total de la confianza ciudadana son
los costos que tiene la propia
recuperación de la democracia y lo que
debemos señalar es que a partir de esta
nueva visión de la gestión de lugo de
luís arce catacora
puedan generar además cambios que nos
permitan trabajar de otra manera el tema
de la justicia de otra manera estos
temas sensibles de la vida nacional esa
es una deuda pendiente que tiene el
estado boliviano con la ciudadanía
trabajar las reformas de la justicia
pero de ahí a comparar la alocución de
luís arce catacora con el racismo
intolerante porque eso si no se puede
tolerar del señor rómulo calvo hay una
distancia horrorosa
vamos llegando a la recta final del
programa quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones comienza por el profesor
nin aquí en el estudio que va a suceder
que escenario ve usted para bolivia para
los próximos meses para lo que resta del
año yo quiero ir más allá del tema
político pues muy caldeado en los
últimos días
quisiera más bien referirme a un informe
que sacó el banco mundial sobre la tasa
de crecimiento que van a tener los
países este año y el siguiente y ahí veo
buenas noticias veo qué bolivia va a
tener una tasa de crecimiento del
producto interno bruto de la riqueza del
país de un 5 por ciento y yo creo que
muchos ciudadanos también están leyendo
ese tipo de indicadores para para poder
apoyar a este gobierno de luís arce
catacora porque eso depende su ingreso
su empleo las ventas de su empresa y
todo lo que está asociado a la
prosperidad económica yo diría que una
vez pasen esto yo creo que el presidente
debe seguir liderando creo que como
economista lo entiende muy bien que si
hay estabilidad económica digamos se
pueden superar incluso las
desaveniencias políticas un factor que
debe aprovechar el presidente ese
entonces el resumen a grandes rasgos
pasó con adolfo tenemos ya pocos minutos
o pocos segundos un 50 segundos adolfo
para la conclusión adelante
primero que no tenemos por qué
comprarnos el falso discurso de que
bolivia hay una polarización
polarización existe cuando existen dos
proyectos distintos de país en este
momento estamos en la construcción de un
proyecto que emerge de la constitución
política del estado lo otro es algo que
está fragmentado y no tiene sentido en
este momento por lo menos en este
momento de hablar de polarización de los
retos que se tienen hacia adelante son
en insistir en la aplicación de la
constitución y expresa empezar a
trabajar sobre la construcción de
sentidos comunes pensando lo común que
nos une y no solamente a partir de las
referencias sociales perfecto al foyer y
acá para el cierre su conclusión
mira mira santiago yo creo sinceramente
que este conflicto en bolivia es un
conflicto
de baja intensidad que tiene ritmos de
muchas veces de mayor intensidad y otras
veces de menor intensidad ahora sí
estamos viviendo es una intensidad
mediana y yo considero que si hay
polarización porque no es casual de que
en varias oportunidades el propio
vicepresidente haya se haya referido a
la necesidad de reconciliación del
reencuentro y de hacer del símbolo de la
wiphala un símbolo del reencuentro entre
los diversos entre los occidentales no
occidentales entre los las comunidades y
las ciudades y este esfuerzo que él ha
señalado que no se puede combatir la
justicia hasta hacer justicia con
injusticia no entonces eso es importante
entonces hay un reconocimiento de
algunos sectores del movimiento al
socialismo que hay una repolarización y
voces como las del hombro tan calvo del
comité cívico y vos es considerar el
resultado pensó que está dispuesto a
matar del diputado del más creo que son
voces aisladas
y que tenemos que marginar y expulsar
del escenario del campo político porque
no son saludables para el país la
economía va a ayudar a la política sin
duda pero también
crecimiento y sabe muy bien el profesor
mina crecimiento no es sino quizás rol
pues a los tras muchísimas gracias por
haber compartido con nosotros sus
opiniones en torno a este tema ustedes
gracias por la sintonía sigan con
nosotros
[Música]